hello and welcome to ed talks with khan
academy i'm kristen de cerva the chief
learning officer here at khan academy
and i'm excited today to talk to ned
johnson who's an author speaker and
founder of prepmatters which is a
company providing academic tutoring
educational planning and standardized
test prep we're going to talk today
about lots of topics including anxiety
and test anxiety so if
you are interested in learning more
about how we can reduce the stress in
our lives and our learners lives stay
tuned
before we get started i want to remind
everyone that at khan academy we are a
non-profit and if you go to
khanacademy.org
donate you can give to help us continue
to complete our mission and to work
towards providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere
also want to thank our uh corporate
sponsors who have stepped up in the time
of covet including a t general motors
vastly if you have uh want to re-listen
to this uh this discussion or find other
discussions between myself sal and other
folks in the in the ed tech space and
education sphere you can join homeroom
with sal the podcast and get audio
version wherever you get your podcasts
so take a look out for that
as i said i'm excited to talk to ned
johnson today he has written three books
the uh
the one that i first learned about was
the self-driven child
and we'll be also talking about his his
most recent book what do you say how to
talk to kids how to talk with kids to
build motivation stress tolerance in a
happy home
so looking forward to our discussion hi
dad welcome
thank you for having me i'm so so
thrilled to talk through this with you
and of course uh like anyone in
education big fan of the great work that
the khan academy does and helping kids
all over the place so thanks for having
me oh thank you absolutely
i'd like to start discussions by asking
people what was your journey how did you
come to
to work in this field of test
preparation and education
well
honestly i graduated college without a
really clear plan of what i was going to
do uh and i followed a friend to the dc
era and i took a job with a local test
prep company who said they were looking
for folks who are good at standardized
tests and like working with high school
students and i'd always been pretty good
at standardized tests and at that point
was pretty nearly a high school student
and i thought well gosh i can give this
give this a try and i just i really fell
in love with talking with teenagers i
just it's such um
paul tuff in his his wonderful book um
the uh the years that matter most now
the inequality machine talks about the
first year of college but i think it
also applies to last year of high school
of sort of the uncertainty what he
describes as the belonging uncertainty
and so during those transitions kids are
vulnerable they're vulnerable to stress
but they're also vulnerable to to new
ideas about themselves uh and there's
just something really cool for me at
least about working one-on-one with kids
and i'm i'm i'm not mom and dad i'm not
asking them to
to clean them the room i'm not a teacher
giving grades i'm just all about what
what trying to help them in all the ways
that are meaningful to them so i've been
i've been something like 50 000 hours
one-on-one talking with kids uh since
since the early 90s and uh it's just it
never gets old it's really cool
that is fantastic
so you write and talk a lot about stress
that's i do start there is is all stress
bad
are there should we think about stress
in different ways at different times
um so so yeah so um first of all all
stress is not bad i mean classically
when we talk about stress
um what there's something called the
your keys dots and curve which some of
your educators may know about it so it's
a bell curve it's a performance curve
and it's really measured in
physiological arousal so kind of what
are those stress hormones what are the
neurotransmitters that are running
through your bodies and brains and if we
have no stress typically there's not
much by way of performance if you play
against a team who's just terrible
you're going to win but you're not going
to play your best at some point you
start to feel butterflies right but
before it began before a big math test
you're trying to talk to somebody thinks
really cute you you should feel that
because it means that you're paying
attention it means that your prime
fraction means that you're ready
the challenge is that more isn't
necessarily better and so at some point
ah then the performance starts to fall
apart and so what we're trying to talk
about is what helps any of us but
especially kids feel like in their place
of what's known as optimal arousal
you're you're amped up enough to be
excited but not so much that you kind of
lose your mind
that makes sense it aligns to i've also
read some uh about the impact of stress
hormones on memory and that a low some
level of stress hormones can actually
help you remember more but then it gets
too high
well yeah and especially you know
one of the things that so my co-author
uh william stickster does it is a
clinical neuropsychologist so he often
works with kids where where things
things aren't going well you know
learning isn't easy attention isn't easy
maybe emotion regulation isn't easy and
both for him as a as a neuropsychologist
and as a test prep geek
we would submit the most important
outcome of high school is not where you
go to college and i don't know my all my
clients like what what but seriously
it's developing the brain that kids are
going to carry into college and then and
then to adulthood and cortisol the
dominant stress hormone
again we need enough of it to kind of
get us out of bed in the morning but too
much
it erodes the hippocampus the major
memory center of the brain it weakens
the connection between the prefrontal
cortex you know the kind of thinking
part of our brain and and the amygdala
and
if you're too tired and too stressed for
too long
very bad things happen to developing
brains and we just don't want to see
young people particularly teenagers who
are really sculpting the brains that
they'll carry into adulthood we just
don't want to see them be stressed all
the time
fine to have intensity work hard
relax hard work hard relax hard that's
kind of just like working out that's how
you get stronger and we want kids to
have that experience but if they're if
they're constantly like this all the
time
just not not good for developing brains
or for test performance for that matter
right right so what are signs that
someone is too stressed and that those
stress levels are too high
oh golly i mean you know there are all
sorts of symptoms when you talk about
you know diagnosed anxiety i mean
you know so i mean it's it's the word
that the words they're using it's it's
the the constant fretfulness it's you
know perfectionism run amok it's
difficulty sleeping it's difficult with
appetite you know with depression i mean
i'm not a clinical psychologist but but
you know that i would if you're if you
really have a kid who you're worried
about mental health just go you know go
to some of the websites that you know
that that will talk about these things
but classically you know but assuming
that's just garden variety anxiety right
which we all experience to a degree
but i really have become interested in
you know for years kind of what i think
of as underperformance
so you know when i first started doing
test pro again i was always pretty good
at these tests i was trained really well
on how to talk about these tests but i
kept having the experience of really
bright you know kids from their great
families their great schools they did
all the hard work and they go and take
the test and go bish
and typically i'd get an irate
phone call from the right i don't
understand we did all the time
right i didn't know i didn't know i
didn't know anything when i was 23 24
doing this
but i was fortunate enough that parents
would send their kids back and we'd have
another another conversation and so i'd
ask them you know did the proctor youth
at the time was the kid next to you
distract you knew you know what what it
looked like and almost always the
conversation would end with something
like
i don't know just it was there was so
much harder than what we did for
practice and so oh okay that makes sense
oh wait wait a second wait wait for all
the reasons that people may not like the
sat or may not like the ect
you know i just don't like standardized
tests generally you have to give them
this
they're standardized so the idea right
that this test that they took was so
fundamentally different than what they'd
done for the you know books of practice
tests just didn't make a lot of sense so
i went to go and take the sct at a local
public high school and i 25 20 you know
i was probably five years into being a
tesla late 20s so i'm sitting there with
all these teenagers and kind of
eavesdropping i'm like what's going
through their heads and you know are
they nervous or anxious whatever and
this isn't i wrote a book years ago
about
called conquering the st about anxiety
and test performance
and for no particular reason i checked
my own pulse
it's a hundred it was 140 beats a minute
140
which is like running down the stairs 15
times and i thought this is curious
because i didn't think that i was
nervous and
i have very few identifiable skills but
one of them is that i've always been
good at standardized tests so like and i
didn't need it because i wasn't going
back to college like what was going on
and so a lot of times kids will be super
well performed prepared in the obama
math test or the sct or whatever happens
to be and we look around and assume well
you didn't study hard enough right that
you know or maybe you're just not that
good you're not as smart as you thought
you were that's a thought that helps
nobody right that the tutor's no good
the program is no good and those are all
things that we might want to consider
but
in some ways if we take seriously the
fact that that test anxiety is rooted in
in
neurochemistry it doesn't part of us
what we work to put hard and they work
hard to put into kids brains that if
under too much pressure perceived stress
they lose their minds then it all goes
for nothing
so i would say um when things are
unexpected is the way that i would look
for anxiety right if a kid is um really
you know is taking this seriously we
have sense of that they've demonstrated
the abilities in other ways and this
class discussion or essays or whatever
how do they perform when there isn't
pressure versus how they perform when
there is pressure and if there's a big
disconnect there then we start thinking
about how do we get more comfortable
with that perceived pressure or or find
ways to down to kind of ratchet down the
perceived pressure of that activity
that makes sense thinking about that
unexpected performance that doesn't
align with what you see in other kinds
of settings and other kinds of ways that
they've demonstrated what they know
all right so how do we help them ratchet
that down what does that look like
well there's there's one place to start
there's um wonderful research by a woman
named sanya lupin who said hits the
center for studies of human stress i
think i got that right in montreal
canada and she has a beautiful acronym
of what makes people nuts okay so nuts
and utils so n is novelty so new
situation so hey it's not just the
coronavirus christmas it's the novel
coronavirus right if you're taking a
test you're like i've never seen that
before it's never a happy thing like if
you're shopping you is unpredictability
so for the work that i do in
standardized tests you know am i going
to have enough time or not if you know
that you won't have time to do three
questions no matter what you do well
that's great to know then we figure out
which three questions do we just not do
right we just fill in those answers
t is per
perceived threat and so pre-code but for
most kids for most of us and
particularly for kids in school that's
threat to ego am i going to look stupid
are people that think i'm an idiot you
know who am i going to think are my
parents going to think are my teachers
going to think
and then s
is a low sense of control and it turns
out this is what the book that bill and
i wrote in the self-different child is
that a low sense of control is the most
stressful thing that people can
experience and so novelty and
predictably you know this is one of the
great things about about the khan
academy is you can have a great teacher
awesome and never need to you know spend
your time with khan or you can have a
teacher you've had three teachers in
chemistry this year because well covet
right and do you feel like i'm
responsible for doing wellness but i
have no way to learn this oh
oh that's really stressful if you know
that there's a tool it's not you gosh
you'd rather learn this at ten o'clock
in the morning with a wonderful teacher
but that's not where i'm right now where
we are right now
so if we think about in a given
situation how much of it is the novelty
how much is it that you feel threatened
how much of you feel those sense of
control and we tack those things in turn
i can talk very credibly about the
values that you that you can find in
standardized tests but i can also talk
until i'm blue in the face about all the
ways that the sct is is a terrible test
and a bunch of ragged muffins and and i
do that with kids
to decrease the stress that they feel
about say look you may need to take this
test for the college that you're
applying to but let's let's let's
disabuse ourselves of the idea that this
is measuring something innate like your
intelligence because golly for most kids
that makes them super super anxious
so that's kind of the first thing is we
want to try to diagnose what's going on
right i mean a lot of kids i work with
they have an older sibling right once
i'm sorry sorry your sister is an
incredible person but she did you know
favors by getting into 1590 on the sat
and rolling off my school
that's kind of intense right and so so
this is something that parents can do
that the teachers can do and you try to
figure out you know where um tina payne
bryson if you know uh you know co-author
of um
uh the whole brainchild and a lot of
other great books talks about stress is
what we perceive when there's a gap
between
the perceived the
what's being required of us and what we
think we're able to do and so we may
want to decrease the demands on a person
or increase the support
now
there's some really fun research and
it's just hard for parents there when
they ask parents kind of what their
expectations are of their kids
and then they also ask them you know and
how much do you think they can actually
meet those expectations
the wider the gap the worse things get
and i just spent a lot of time with
parents trying to talk them down for now
these expectations that you have to go
to princeton i love orange but really
four years affords i mean it's not the
only place in the world to go
um but it's i mean it's complicated kids
are complicated parenting is complicated
um but that would be the first place
that i that i would start um
i mean
we talk about a lot i spent the amount
of money that i've been paid to talk
with kids about sleep that i have not
been paid to be talked about sleep
deprivation i've been paid to help them
you know prepare for these tests but i
talk i i can talk for hours about what
sleep deprivation does
to brains one to developing brains but
two from a performance just for folks
who don't know i mentioned a little
while ago cortisol was the dominant
stress hormone
when we're sleep deprived
the amygdala the the stress reaction is
about 60 more reactive and our bodies
just pumping out cortisol and so we're
we're stressed all the time there's a
kid i was working with years ago i
mentioned princeton she had an older
brother who went to princeton as a
baseball player she was super academic
but found tess harder part because she
was just more stressed more easily than
you know maybe her brother was so we're
doing the act and she has taken this
test
far too many times
and it's we're meeting on a sunday she's
taking a test the following saturday
we're doing all the last minute review
and she's an academic kid great family
and i finally say and reminder that you
know if you can be in bed by 10 or 10 30
you're going to do so much better on the
test well then i'm in the middle of this
in her face hauls
and i'm like
what
you should say well
my friends and her friends are great and
they're super important she's a 17 year
old girl i get that i said i understand
i understand but for one week could we
maybe just like you know just hang it up
with the phone in the kitchen to get a
bit early
maybe
so what if what if your mom paid you to
go to bed she's like my mom wouldn't pay
me i'm like
what if i paid you she's like what and i
said
but i don't trust you so your mom's in
church you have to hand your phone to
your mom at 10 o'clock and if your bed
lights up i'll give you 20 bucks and she
said
for for you know for for the week i said
i'll give you 20 every night she said no
you won't i said yes i will she said no
i said watch me
she shows up on friday we have one last
more to do and i hand her 5 dollar bills
no this is wealth redistribution is
really her parents money and she goes
off and gets the test i mean she and she
had always been capable she could have
probably done this months ago
if she could have been less stressed
so sleep deprivation is a big deal um
there's a wonderful book i'll hold this
up called choke it's a provocative title
if you know this this is cyan biology
she's now the president of barnard
college she is incredible
love love love her work and she looks at
underperformance public speaking
athletic standardized tests
and one of her models is the idea of
having the mindset
of a predator
rather than a prey
because the prefrontal cortex decision
making planning problem solving
emotional mental flexibility
all executive functions of the
prefrontal cortex the amygdala the free
spider flight response you don't want to
freeze you can't run away and there's
nobody to bite right in the middle of a
test so we really don't want that part
of our brain going off and she says if
you lean in with what she describes this
is kind of having more swagger
you're going to it can help you perform
better so i actually did i got i did a
tick tock thing in the day to shoot me
now i know old people tick tock but
whatever
and so i stumbled on this great research
at nih that found this of executive
functions we know
that stress really messes with executive
functions being anxious bad bad bad but
you know what doesn't
being angry
so if you're worried about the sat or
your math test or whatever if you're
like don't drag them up and say
you're better off
angry then you are being anxious because
you'll actually think
better
so there's that so interesting you have
more questions
i'll talk about a minute but please jump
in
yeah no that was great so you talked
about
um
lowering the you know lowering the
threshold when we think about teachers
we have a question that that came in
thinking about um
from from aviv what are actions teachers
can take to help their students prepare
for that stress of assessment so even if
we're not talking sat we could be
talking classrooms oh yeah yeah um yeah
that's the great part is i mean things
that teachers can do
yeah yeah i mean there there are several
things i mean first of all
um there's a wonderful study that that
when we when when students i think they
were taking a great i can't remember but
this of course applies to all tests
when they were when kids were test
takers reminded
that some anxiety back to that bell
curve actually improves their
performance right that actually you want
to have some butterflies before the test
that actually helps you focus
that improved their performance because
then they weren't worried about being
worried worried they felt what they're
feeling physiologically they felt as
this is me preparing
you know to go do battle right
that's super helpful um
the same sonja lupine of the nuts one of
the things that she talks about this
incredibly useful
to like the probably the single best
tool to lower stress is plan b
thinking
i am
so happy for test optional i can't even
tell you
because it lowers the stress you know of
course you would love to get a fifteen
hundred because who wouldn't and applied
for a fantastic right because you look
great in orange i'm sure but goodness
knows you know if you don't get a 1500
we know what you do you can still apply
to princeton you know and you know what
happens if you don't go to princeton
they're like 3 500 in colleges where you
can also get you know and so and so we
have to in order to talk about that plan
b thinking
a teacher really needs to have a good
relationship with the kid
lest the the kid feel like you're trying
to say you're saying i can't do this not
what i'm saying at all i'm saying that
it will help you if right
um from a stress perspective bill and i
in the in the self-driven child we talk
about
the the chapter in the book called a
non-anxious
presence and i wish we'd made this up
because it's such a good term we
borrowed this from a guy named edwin
freeman was a rabbi he was a consultant
he worked with schools and searchers and
synagogues and families and he simply
made the point that things work better
when the person or people in charge
aren't overly emotional aren't
overreactive and because
stress is contagious and but the good
news is this all emotions are contagious
calm is contagious we discover this when
calm is contagious
is a mantra of the navy seals
so
when if your kids come to you and
they're super spun up right if you can
say you know um eli leibowitz uh uh the
guy um
um professor about of anxiety what's
called the space program we'll go into
it at yale talks about making supportive
statements
and supportive statements are simply
saying yeah that i i get that this is
really hard for you i can see that
you're pretty stressed out about this
and i have every confidence that you can
deal with this i'm confident you can
handle this and i'll help you in any way
that i can
because so often we try to oh my gosh
it's not such a big deal christians just
oh my gosh did you three years from now
who'll even care
well i'm trying to help you but i'm
really invalidating what you're feeling
and you're feeling what you're feeling
for whatever reason but we also say i
have every confidence that this is going
to work on and if it doesn't work out
just the way you want we can do this and
i bet you can do this and you're going
to figure out a way to make this work
even if it's a plan b
so you know we in in our new book what
do you say
we use we have a lot of scripts there a
lot of language because
it's hard as a teacher when kids come at
you with things and they're super spun
up and your heads are thinking oh my
goodness
we could be seeing this differently but
what we're really trying to do is get
thank you yeah that's the book um bill
sticks your genius what we're really
trying to do is get buy-in in order to
have kids be open to our messages we
really just start with empathy and
validation it makes sense to me that
you're pretty stressed out about this
sat it feels like a big deal i it makes
sense to me you know i i can get that
you're pretty feel pretty intense about
this test coming right now because there
is some hard there's some hard stuff on
that but i'm confident that you can
handle this so um you know
i don't want to put one more thing on
the backs of teachers who are she feels
like they're shouldering the weight of
the world right now
but but i will say that
if there's any single thing that is
valuable to young people right now
it's having a close connection to one or
more adults if there's a silver bullet
against the effects of stress on
developing brains it's feeling it's
feeling close connection to to an adult
ideally that's parents when we were
writing this book we asked we're meeting
with all these kids and we ask them who
do you feel closest to in the world
sometimes with mom sometimes his dad is
sometime a grandma my aunt my uncle
sometimes a teacher i'm sitting in right
now in washington dc and right across
the street from us is wilson high school
it's kind of the big public high school
in northwest terrific school great
learners um and we're working with we
were talking a bunch of these kids and
this one and so in the follow-up
question we said what what about those
people makes you feel close to them and
there are two things one
they listen to me without judging
and two they don't tell me what to do
all the time so this boy went on to talk
about this biology teacher who was just
like this fountain of wisdom and calm
he she wasn't his teacher
she wasn't his teacher she'd never had
him as a teacher he'd never had her as a
teacher excuse me but she was just known
as the person and all these kids would
just come in there and they would just
have lunch with her and she just asked
about their stuff and i'm sure they told
her some crazy stuff
and and and lily just being a person
where you can go oh that's interesting
tell me more about that um because it's
incredibly valuable for lowering stress
and
for developing motivation we can talk
about motivation if you want but i'm an
enormous fan of what's called we are
enormous fans of what's known as
self-determination theory and it's a
model for intrinsic motivation you
probably know you know all about that
yes go ahead and explain it i'm a big
fan too
but the idea that you know so often we
think you know parents teachers school
systems politicians we've got to get
kids to work hard well from my
perspective i have zero interest in kids
working hard i have interest in their
wanting to work hard because extrinsic
motivation of fear or bribes
they work for a while but it's a
terrible way to grow up with a brain
simply trying to meet other people's
expectations of you what we really want
is kids to do the work right um jess
leahy you know the gift of failure
people i know love her work i saw talk
shopping with a bunch of teachers and
asked them and this one teacher said you
know what the three r's of teaching are
relationships relationships
relationships
and so good teachers are worth their
weight in gold because they don't get
kids to work hard they get kids to want
to work hard like when i whenever i meet
with kids the first you know the first
day is trying to understand them as a
learner like what's your favorite class
what's your least favorite class oh you
love math that is that the class or is
that the teacher and as you can imagine
more than half the time it's oh you know
it's pretty good oh miss rodriguez she's
just i don't know she makes it so
interesting and part of that is that she
makes the math interesting but
that she's interested
in them
right and so again i just you know i
wish i wish teachers
i wish teachers had more autonomy i wish
they had less on their plates so that
they just it was easier for them to put
as much time and energy as they wanted
to there in real in the relationships
because for anyone who's an old part
like me when you think back about the
class that you love most i can remember
you can remember so little of what we
learned but i can remember mr broberman
and just how much i love this guy as a
history teacher i took zero history in
college but i loved him as a teacher
right and that's what great teachers do
right
yeah yeah absolutely let's take one more
question from youtube um the handle math
with tga says how do i clear my mind
after a big failure
so you can imagine you've failed at
something or that causes a lot of stress
how do you get over that and go for that
you know what the next steps are going
to be
well
gosh i mean
one thing there's um uh lisa de moore if
you if you know i love all these people
and she's choosing she's a previous and
talks guest oh i just love her you know
and she makes the point that
mental health
is the right feeling for the right
situation
so if you really worked hard at a test
and you feel like you bombed it
you're allowed to be upset right you
shouldn't be saying i shouldn't be upset
look you're going to be busy like gosh
darn it i really worked hard in that
but
we then have to move on right what the
real challenge is when people get locked
in rumination they beat themselves and
beat themselves up and beat themselves
up and beat themselves up and what we
want to try to do is if you go back to
that plan and be thinking what else can
i do
now the reality is i love the site this
is a success coach i follow in the 80s
who made the point that unexpected
success
and unexpected failures those are what
provide the source material for great
insights on your own life
so it's worth trying what happened there
right so talk to your math teacher talk
to your friends compare notes reflect
was i really well prepared you know did
i
was i well rested what was going on what
was my subjective state what did it feel
like going in there i mean i feel that
the kids every year in school and i
don't know what grade the student is in
we should have to work harder we
shouldn't re-engineer ourselves as
learning because if you're not having to
do things more or differently in 11th
grade that you did in seventh grade like
boy a lot of people's time is being
wasted here right um
there's a wonderful wonderful wonderful
book called make it stick
it's henry rodiger the third and a bunch
of people um if there's a if you send
out notes afterwards he has they have
they i forget the other authors i just
know his name
michael brown i think david brown
somebody brought they have a fantastic
piece in psychology today
with basically the six takeaways from
make it stick and it's things you know
all the stuff it's based learning it's
sleep it's it's um um the testing effect
right so retrieval practice so we don't
just look at our notes we actually kind
of test ourselves there's a lot of great
stuff there and so it's worth when i
think about underperformance on tests
you know math tests sat and that kind of
thing i try to think about was it the
input or was it the output meaning
did i test myself in ways that i know
that i really learned it
and if i because if i just think i had a
i knew it might have been a little trick
my brain was playing on me in which case
i want to examine how it is that i'm
learning was i just cramming it but if i
really knew the stuff
and i underperformed well then it's a
performance piece right so we're back to
you know what blows up cortisol what
helps you get your you know swagger on
right you know what gets you like hulk
smash mode when you take the test right
listening to music um i'm a huge uh the
number of students who
to whom i have prescribed the sun the
seven minute workout you know um sonia
if people don't know this um it's it's
seven it's 12 30 second exercises that
you can do anywhere you need no exercise
equipment at all you need a chair
because oh if we'll go back to sony
lupine i love her she's just a genius
she says the four methods of emergency
stress relief are these
laughing
singing
deep breathing
and vigorous exercise right well
laughing and singing probably aren't too
available to during the test you know
maybe beforehand vigorous exercise for
sure you can do this in paul tuff's book
he has a the chat there's a whole
chapter about me i won't go into long
story but basically showing up in this
girl's
going to her house and doing soul cycle
with that it's a whack-a-doodle story at
like 6 30 in the morning of an act it's
it's bonkers and and to blow off the
cortisol super academic super tightly
mined i couldn't get her to sleep more
and just she sort of gasped herself for
20 minutes took a shower i
went away and got the score because
because too much cortisol she was just
on the wrong side of that bell curve
um and then the deep breathing is a big
thing um people probably know the box
breathing that the navy seals created i
mean these are people who have you know
probably high intensity performance
anxiety right
and deep breathing
purges cortisol out of our nervous
system and brings it back to normal i
mean i pre covet i was still taking the
sat shoulder to shoulder with teenagers
you know just to know what it feels like
and i can sit down feel my pulse is
still going like crazy
because i'm an old guy in a room full of
teenagers like that's weird right but i
want to know what it feels like and i
sit there when i'm filling in my actress
i do deep breathing
and it brings me back down
i'm not altering kilo but i'm in this
place where i'm amped up but not not
crazy um so again i think of the input
in testing to really know the stuff look
up make it stick it's wonderful but then
if you really know that you learned it
well then we start thinking about these
aspects of performance and it may be and
it may be a little bit of a and a little
bit of b
great great
we are just about out of time i do want
to um as you say in your new book you
provide lots of scripts and things to
ask let me ask you this question that
comes up a lot when talking to parents
how do i ask something to get to my kids
to say give me an answer other than fine
when i say
how are you doing fine how was school
today fine
how can we
encourage kids to express their emotions
yeah i mean
how golly i mean first of all it's
probably helped for us to remind
ourselves that teenagers especially part
of their work to become adults is to
individually indeed individuate from mom
and dad right so they're that they're
supposed to push away from us a little
bit right and so they run away and then
they come back and run they come back i
mean a few thoughts the first is for the
love of p please ask them about things
other than school
because so many kids feel like you know
there's an article i'm still wanting to
get and you know some paper you know
that we have basically adam's um
let's think her how was school how are
your grades where are you applying to
college do you have a boyfriend or
girlfriend as though that's the sum
total of their experience right so if
you're getting the if you're getting the
fine stop asking stop asking about
school okay but i have a specific thing
to that i'll come back then in a moment
um you know ask about kind of everything
else particularly asking about their
hobbies what are they interested you
know politics every everything else in
the in the world um also if you have a
kid where there's you know there's a
problem you know they don't have friends
at school right they're having a hard
time that's a hard thing when we keep
asking about the thing that's a problem
we're kind of interviewing for pain
we're looking well you know and because
in many ways what parents i think are
trying to do is they really just want to
be told that it's okay so they don't
have to worry about this but in this
situation you're being the opposite of
non-anxious presence you're feeling like
i have to check over and over and over
and make sure that when okay just like
did you do homework did you do your
homework did you do your homework did
you do it
right it's it's putting all the energy
into that right where what was for lunch
today what was the weirdest thing that
happened what's going on i mean you know
particularly with the last two years of
covet you know taking an interest in
what your kids are watching to tick tock
right if you you know if you want your
kids to be open with you
try to ask them about things other than
they give you information and then and
they feel like they're going to be in
trouble or they can be criticized for it
if it is what's the weirdest thing you
saw today that's funny that's fun yeah
and if you're and if it is something in
school you know so you know so i don't
know you know what was the what was the
hardest thing that popped up in
chemistry what was the dopiest thing you
saw try to make those questions a lot
more specific because yeah if you ask
how was school of course they're going
to say fine because if they say well it
was really hard they feel like they're
going to be interviewed or grilled about
the thing well wait a second what do you
mean you didn't do all this
they don't want to hear about this
because this is really interesting to me
in writing this book we realized that
one of the things is that
a lot of kids don't want to share
the hard parts of school life
friendships with their parents
because they don't want to burden their
parents they don't want to get their
parents upset and
they it's too much for them to deal with
their parents intense feelings on top of
their heart feelings
so this is where so this is where kids
say fine even though we know it's not
fine
so i will share this particular piece of
advice if you have a kid where you know
things are not fine
um but you can't get them to talk to you
so i think daughter is a senior in high
school and she is a complicated bird she
is brilliant for 30 iq points my dad um
has had her share of dark things the
last couple years have not been easy for
her
and when she is unhappy
she just closes down you know she's you
know the kid in the in the cave and she
and and so the conversation will often
look like they you know hey kid are you
okay
that's what she does she shrugs her
shoulders i'm like
any anything anything i can help with
and i'll ask two or three questions like
that and she's not giving it up and in
many ways
in many ways these are her feelings and
these are hers to feel it's not my
responsibility i know that sounds like a
talent thing to do but honestly it's an
important thing for young people to
learn to be able to talk themselves out
of hard feelings if she can only get
back to baseline because of me i'm not
doing my job as a dad
so what i've done with her is this
is validate and then offer support right
and then step away and say well so boy
sweetheart it sure looks like you know
you had a day of it because i don't know
what's going on but you look really
upset if there's any way that i can help
please know you know if you want to
listen if you want to if you want to
yeah i'll do whatever i can do to help
right is that okay shoulder shrug
here's the question i said ask is it all
right if i circle back in about half an
hour just to check in and make sure
you're doing okay
get the head nod and i swear
every time i've done this
if i say i'll be back in a half an hour
in 20 minutes she's bounced downstairs
if i say i'll come back an hour she
comes down in 40 minutes every single
time
and she's just in whatever cloud it is
that's been in her mind has just passed
and not once
have i found out what she was upset
about i knew she was upset she knew she
was upset but she just didn't want to
share and so this is the way we as
parents can we offer support we offer
help for our could be a lot of times for
kids to know that we're there to help
even if they don't take us up on the
help
is helpful
thank you i'm going to close on that
that seems like
that's an excellent note for us to
to leave on thank you so much for
joining us today
really appreciated all the information
you shared and uh look forward to diving
into the new book
i hope you enjoyed i really appreciate
again i i love that you i love that the
khan academy is taking all of the kind
of technical stuff you teach everything
and really trying to broaden it with
with some of the folks and i'm grateful
i'm grateful to be among among those so
thank you
absolutely
thanks all for watching today we'll see
you next time
you